this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart more on that later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler you know me as
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
uh thank you guys for uh all your
support man the
the community continues to grow please
subscribe to the youtube page that's
a really great way to help the show uh
there's a lot of free ways to help the
show
you know subscribing to the youtube page
a five-star review stuff like that
don't just watch subscribe um and the
patreon show the honeydew with y'all
is it's absolutely one of my favorite
things to do is sit and talk to you guys
about your
your life stories and i'm blown away by
the younger crowd that's coming around
you were saying right before we started
how much you hate your paycheck
you're like i have to do this [ __ ] i
[ __ ] hate it
but okay i guess i guess you're
different on air
on air he said we're on air live from
the honeydew studio
i mean i just it was just caught me off
guard from what you said moments ago
all right don't [ __ ] with my income
during the pandemic bro
ah right uh the patreon show if you or
someone you know has a story that
absolutely needs to be heard please
submit it at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com it's five bucks a month it's
60 bucks a year and yes i say it every
week it is a lot of money for some
people right now i know it
it's a utility bill you're on
unemployment all that so if you do have
the means and you can support i
appreciate you and
giving one back to you if you sign up
for a year you'll get like a month plus
a free episode so there's that as well
facebook fan page uh honeydew the
honeydewpodcast.com is a website for
everything the merch is there
i cannot believe the amount of night
pants we're selling y'all night pants
nation
is we we outsold the damn pattern
at the place that makes the night pants
all right i can't
it just makes me laugh it's absurd it's
absurd night shorts you all came up with
that idea
buying the [ __ ] out of those thank you
very much uh the night pants nation
sweats the hoodies all of it's all there
now um if you live in l.a or if you need
musical instruments or lessons for your
kids you know i record here at santa
monica music center
you can take online classes from la
musicians you just go to santa monica
music dot com
use the code honeydew they're gonna
waive the registration fee and they're
gonna give you one free lesson
when you sign up for a package all right
that's everything going on now
if you're new to the show welcome thank
you for coming on if you're not
subscribed to the damn youtube channel
and uh what we do over here is we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers
today's storyteller very excited to have
here first time this time on the
honeydew
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
brooks will y'all hey me that's me
welcome to the honey thanks i'm stoked
to do it thank you for being here
yeah i know it's a wild time right now
and i know you've been wanting to do it
i did your podcast too
which i had a great time doing so before
we we have some good stuff to talk about
um some terribly wonderful stuff and uh
please promote everything you'd like i
mean i just have uh
i've got a podcast that you did called
entry level it's about uh all the jobs
that
you had before that uh you were a
professional comedian and uh your
episode was [ __ ] incredible you were
a full uh
junkyard boy yeah you're like a junkyard
dog and a junkyard boy
yeah uh but yeah it's great you go check
out entry level with brooks wheeling
i've had
ever if you like comedy i've interviewed
somebody you really like like it's a
huge spectrum
yeah no doubt it's a great show yeah
it's fun as hell uh so that's all i'm
doing
you can check out my stand-up comedy if
you just you know type my name into the
internet
all right yeah all right you find it
that way um so i
as always i ask every guest to go
through trauma you and i have been
talking here
and and you there's a few things you
mentioned a broken engagement which
resonates with me but
but prior to that you got one of the
greatest jobs
right well i had i didn't know how to
deal with trauma because
honestly i mean no one does things
worked pretty
well for the first 27 years is that
right
yeah it just all went according to plan
okay and then
it stopped so here's the funny thing
it's not funny but it is it's more like
if the reverse for me
the first 30 was like [ __ ] and then
it's sort of level i wouldn't it's
leveled off and gotten better yeah right
yeah well it wasn't like it wasn't you
know i just grew up in the woods in iowa
uh and i wanted to do stand-up comedy in
order to get on
saturday night live and my family you
know the no
the rural parts of iowa are you know the
idea of like hey i want to be on tv
shut the [ __ ] up yeah i'd like to go to
the moon uh so i was like okay i'll go
to college i'll get a biomedical i'll
get a biomedical engineering degree oh
really yeah that's why i went and got a
biomedical engineering degree in
cardiovascular biomechanics
at the university of iowa it's really
cheap to go in state i was like okay i'm
gonna use this degree
to move to new york or la to pursue
comedy to get on snl
and then they did it and it all happened
and it was
exactly according to paul yes so did you
use that degree for a job while you're
trying to get snl what were you doing
that degree i worked at edwards life
sciences uh in um
you're really intelligent yeah i was
making artificial heart valves edwards
life sciences is a great company top
part valve company in the world so can i
ask you a question
we had a guest on um andrew rose a
comedian
a local la comedian he was on the
patreon episode he told us about this
he has a pacemaker that has a
defibrillator in it yeah you know those
i mean i mostly i like super laser
focused on uh
heart valves specifically specifically
valves and there's three
companies that manufacture them but i
mean like i'm familiar of like
your er like arrhythmia and [ __ ] like
that
also what made you go into that major
were you always like fascinated with the
heart or the body
no it was just like uh so i was like at
first i was like well comedy seems like
you know i knew i wanted to do it as a
kid but i was like that seems impossible
so i'll be a doctor
because that's what you do uh which also
to me seems impossible right well that
one is actually more impossible very
hard if you're dumb
like me or like to party like me uh
so i was like okay i'll get a biomedical
engineering is a great
um pre-med degree so you so i was like
doing that but then
halfway through my freshman year of
college i tried stand up i was like no
no no i'm going to do this forever
but i was like i'm just going to finish
this degree so i just
picked cardiovascular biomechanics
because
i was like oh i just was interested in
the heart and the heart valve and
i wrote this big paper on it i was like
okay this would be an easy way to get a
job
so i just did that it was just kind of
like well what do you want to do i was
like i don't
want to leave that's all i want to do so
then i you know
picked this elective focus area and then
applied for these three
places saint jude medtronic and edwards
where these are the three heart valve
places
they're all out here in southern
california um
down in irvine and uh i got one of them
and so i moved to er i moved to
huntington beach and i was cool i'm in
l.a
okay no i wasn't uh and then you know
worked
at edwards life sciences for two years
um doing r d for
this new uh transcatheter heart valve
that's out now that's [ __ ] incredible
and like if i still follow
great company like i really respect them
they fired me and it was one of those
firings where it was like no
yeah absolutely i can't believe it
i can't believe i got this yeah they
were like we have a guy here to escape
from a vacation right yeah they're like
we have someone to escort you out and i
was like you don't need to i'm not mad
at you
this is nuts you're doing the right
thing yeah it was it takes me two years
at a job before they're like
here's the worst thing that can happen
at your job is your boss
brings you into their office and they go
walk us through your day
like what do you do yeah and i'm like
well let me go let me go think about it
because i'm gonna have to lie a lot uh
any time i've ever been fired it's all
i've laughed out loud because like do
you need a box for your things i'm like
no
i'm not i never made this a personal
[ __ ] space i like the pictures of my
family yeah
i am also not embarrassed
yeah i'm high-fiving people i think i
threw out [ __ ] her
yeah so i got booted from there because
i was doing comedy so much
you know i was just come i was driving
from irvine to hollywood
every day that's like three hours
in traffic yeah it's it was brutal yes
it was so there was getting home at like
two in the morning waking up at
six to go into work so i could leave by
two which also you can't do from an
engineering job
just i'm out it's like two band you
don't get to leave now it's like well i
do
and they're like well you're fired um so
i got fired from there
still respect that company though uh and
then i worked for a small startup at
caltech
on in on interocular lenses uh for two
years
and then the day i was getting demoted
from
full-time to he was like well also okay
so
everything good starts happening comedy
wise like i go to montreal then i go
audition for
snl i meet with lauren michaels so you
came you came to california first you
came west
yeah so yeah i spent some time in i
started in iowa and then i would drive
to chicago
like every weekend to do stand up so i
was like three years of
commuting to chicago back and forth so
when i moved out here all my friends
were the guys from chicago
which turned out to be really great
comics yeah and powerhouses
yeah i was kind of like no doubt like
the camille's and
like pete holmes and con canaines were
out here and i had like
done open mics with them in chicago so
they're like oh yeah i remember this guy
um but then so i then i go and i'm
like 26 yeah 26 and i thought i got
snl because things had gone so well and
uh
then so i stopped going to my job
because i was like well i'm gonna go
be on snl and but i didn't tell my job
because i'm still i'm like well i still
don't have any [ __ ] money
uh so i still getting paid i didn't go
in for a week
uh sat at home just like i think i'm
gonna you know what am i gonna do you
know i'm gonna
and then they release four new hires at
snl and i wasn't one of them and i was
like oh
no oh no
ah so uh i just walked back into work
like you hadn't been gone where have you
been
you weren't calling or telling nothing
collecting a paycheck you bet
uh you called that a no-call no-show
yeah so i walked back in and sat down
and he was like what
like what are you doing i was like i
don't i was you know i was working from
home and he's like you run the lab you
can't
work from home this is you're in charge
of this lab
this is not an at-home project he was
really nice i really like him a lot his
name is charles he's [ __ ] rad
and he was like very cool to me always
and he was like look man we're just
going to have to
we're just going to have to put you on
part-time you know because i was leaving
a lot
to go to new york and montreal and now
touring a little bit and i was like i
get that and then
at lunch i got called to i was gonna go
right at snl they hired me to be a
writer
so i was like hey charles good news for
everybody everybody yeah
yeah he was really happy yeah he was
great yeah so it just like all had gone
according to plan you know like
everything i
tried so from your audition your first
thing was a writer your first
job at snl was a right yeah and then i
[ __ ] talked lauren into putting me in
the cast
which was not hard i was like dude i
gotta be in this gas
[ __ ] you know i was just way too
confident i had never uh
failed at anything and then i did the
show and it was like a big
failure it was sucked and i was like i'd
like i
never thought like i was like oh i want
to be an engineer i can learn how to be
an engineer i was like
oh everybody stand up comic and learn
how to be a stand-up congressman oh now
i'm gonna be honest now i'm gonna learn
how to be on snl
and then uh that was the first time i
didn't i couldn't i just couldn't do it
what what was it you couldn't do because
i know the schedules grew uh
you know grueling and well no it was
just competition i just had no
idea i didn't know anybody and i thought
you know i'm gonna show them
how good i am by not asking for help and
writing
all sketches myself just by myself you
know being friends with people but like
only having my name on sketches which i
thought was a good idea
it's not a good idea
because it's a huge hierarchy there of
like you know the head writers have been
there 10 years
like their sketches are if there's like
any doubt like which one's funnier we're
going to go with the person who's
seen senior so i didn't realize i should
be pairing up
asking [ __ ] the head writers like hey
you want to write with me who were the
heads when you were there um it was
uh brian tucker colin jost
uh seth meyers um it just but
not even necessarily those guys just
other writers you know and then i
figured that out and it was just tough
it was just
a real like i cried a lot man like
because it was like
four four times it happened where you
work like 90 to 100 hours
and then i have this my sketch that i'm
working on that i'm the main guy and
that i get to be very funny in
i would always have the um final sketch
of the night not always just had to
happen four times
but uh so i have the final sketch of the
night incredible i can't wait there's so
many [ __ ] hurdles to get this far
uh and it's really funny and i love it
and it's crazy and i cannot wait
for the world to see it it's so cool you
know and i've spent 80 hours in the last
three days working on this i don't even
know if that's many hours in three days
i don't think so 72 uh either way
so i am so excited so excited so excited
it's happening four [ __ ] times
then like i'm in my dumb wig or whatever
and they come over they go hey we ran
long sketch cut
so four times i'm like adrenaline can't
wait to do live snl
my only time i'm gonna be on the show
like i'm like i don't care it's my
sketch i'm funny
in it i don't give i never give a [ __ ]
about playing the janitor or whatever
who would just walk through
i always said that she was lame even
though that's what you need to do
um and so then i would just be like what
the [ __ ] like it was just a big gut
punch
and that was really hard all right so
let's go back to
obviously elation of getting the writing
gig you come in now you've
you've talked them into putting you in
the cast which wasn't the original plan
at least you talked them in giving you
the chance to be yeah the original plan
lauren told me
because and he was right i was wrong he
was like
you're very green you're too green he
i'd never been on tv i'd never done
stand up on tv
this was your first television credit
too yeah okay so
uh there was never any like comedy
sentence i did like adam devine's house
party but it hadn't aired yet
you know and that's very different uh
and um
so what year is this by the way 2013.
and he was just like
you're very greedy how old were you 20
oh this is also a sign i got
called to be a writer on my 27th
birthday and they call it hey you're
going to be on
snl you know hey you're going to come we
don't know what you're going to do here
yet but at least you're going to be a
writer i go the least that's the [ __ ]
greatest job i've ever heard of
uh and then i was like it's my birthday
and that's what i told uh this woman who
hired me and this is just for shout out
and she goes
i don't care oh yeah wow
i don't care just get to new york i was
like oh okay that's maybe a little sign
that they're a little mean there
uh not like cool don't care yeah i don't
care
all right okay oh
that is great right so
either way i go there and then lauren
told me he's like hey you're too green
to be on the show this year
we're going to have you right this year
and we're going to put you in the cast
next year
which i was like dude i'm ready right
now looking back
that was a great plan because it's very
scary intimidating show
the first time you ever see it you're on
it in the cold open it's just [ __ ]
terrifying
uh and i was like oh if i was here for a
year making friends and
you know it helps a lot if you go from
writer to cast
because the writers like you you know
you're what you're
you're already ingratiated you know um
so it was just tough and then you know i
wasn't sure if i was gonna get
fired or not like it was i was very much
50 50 it could go either way
uh and then when it happened it was like
the first ever
failure like giant failure i've ever had
it was [ __ ]
very devastating what was your first
sketch that you actually got on camera
uh the first one that i got on was me
doing a weekend update
uh about my tattoos so you like slid in
in the chair slid in did a stand-up bit
about bad tattoos
i mean how great was that that was
that's the coolest moment i've ever had
real quick how many show how many shows
do they do a season
24 okay so what show is this that you
make it on
third wow okay so third of the season
who's the host
[ __ ] i don't even know a lot of them
because
i wasn't interacting with the host and
who are your is it tina and jimmy
then no this was oh yes
and it was great it was the coolest i i
cause until then i'd been in some
sketches
like but i hadn't written them you know
and so this was the first time i was
like okay i've contributed
and changed and made put uh at least
some sort of stamp that i was here on
this show and i wrote a thing
myself and i did it and you know the
whole reason i want to do snl is because
adam sandler rolled on and was adam
sandler's like i get to roll on and be
me
like this was the [ __ ] goal in iowa
so you came on as brooks whale and not
some character
right yeah i got to do two of those
which were uh
by pharmaceutical come on yeah yeah um
so yeah no it was the season started off
okay
because i got i did that on the third
show and then on the fourth show i did
my only good
sketch which was me and edward norton
these critter control guys
uh who get pulled into a wall and
murdered by possums it's really funny
and i was really like so by the fourth
show i'm like i [ __ ] got it
like this is great i get how this works
uh and then i was blanked for 10 shows
which is like four months
blank meaning no sketches i didn't get
anything no roles
like no funny roles no fun didn't get to
be funny once
for like 10 episodes that's so long
to just be blank yeah and that i was
spun out it was really
sad and then i got over that and then
the last like
six episodes i got like a sketch to
dress each time and i was like okay cool
i'm figuring out like the last half of
the season is super fun
uh but then fired and just like really
really
how did that go down well it was wild
uh i mean also did lauren call you in
and say oh [ __ ] no
walk us through your day no no no no no
no
i would have told him i'd be like i'm in
there today i'm working
i'm sleeping in the 5's leaving jay
farrell's dressing room because he has
no way i hope you didn't talk about
references yeah
[Laughter]
no man it was just i was walking with
how does it happen well i was just
walking with my
there's a day you get renewed also the
the [ __ ]
contract is you can't quit for seven
years but we can fire you
every six months oh really they're they
get you for a minimum of seven but they
yeah they can renew you you can get out
of it you know look
i mean if there's one thing and i i i
feel weird talking about it but i guess
i do know
a lit like more than because to me my
friends are guys who've done the show 10
years i'm like
so i don't really know as much as they
know you know but i did do it for one
year and i know that
lauren is reasonable if you want out and
need out who will definitely let you out
you know
um but the contract is seven
uh so there's like a date you get
renewed on
uh july 15th and i remember i was like
walking with my girlfriend or whatever
uh on houston on avenue a we were in the
grocery store and
um yes phone rings or whatever it's my
reps
and you know and they're like hey what's
up and i was like well that's not a
you're coming back yeah tone and i go uh
nothing
did i get fired and they go yeah
no way to say it yeah and i was like
ooky duke you know and it was just kind
of just like a real
it was a real blur you know it was just
like [ __ ] you know and it's kind of
my girlfriend was really nice and we
just kind of sat outside it was this uh
grocery store on
a and in house didn't really and uh yeah
just kind of real blurry you know
and then just walked home uh and then
it fired from new york it's saturday
night and then yeah
yeah yeah which i'd uh which my friend
tim robinson
he called me he's like you had that one
in the hopper didn't you yeah
i thought of that one
and then they had the balls to like
reach out and be like look you weren't
fired you were just not renewed i go
you're not my boss anymore that's
yeah yeah come on yeah we're just not
bringing you back yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah uh yeah and then
i just you know and then
it like lit a real fire under my ass to
go back to stand up i'm like i'm not a
[ __ ] sketch comic i'm a [ __ ]
stand-up
um because that's the other thing and
i'm sure you get it like i was like i
want to be an snl and then when i turn
21 i'm like i don't need to be honest
and i just love stand-up comedy
and then so it wasn't like my goal
wasn't trying to get on snl i was just
trying to be the best stand-up
comedian in the world working on my own
tv shows and [ __ ] and then by virtue of
trying to do that i got the show so it's
not like i was trying to
right get on the show it just like
happened which is [ __ ] wild
uh yeah there was just really kind of
bummed and then i did i feel like the
biggest mistake i ever made in my life
was not moving back to la
right away okay that's what i was going
to ask you stayed there in new york to
do stand up
well just kind of just to say [ __ ] you i
moved my whole life
here like you're not i'm not gonna do
what at whatever
it was just out of spite i lived in new
york for like another year out of spite
just why would you say it's the biggest
mistake because i
was miserable okay i didn't all of my
friends
every one of them worked at the show
that had fired me
so like when the show's on they have an
on week i don't have anybody to hang out
with
you know and then one time one time i
went up there to write with them on a
riding night and i was like
i came home and just cried my girl was
like you cannot go back to that building
and go
yeah that was a huge mistake i remember
like bill hader was hosting
and like i was really good friends with
like tim robinson zach cannon and
michael che
and i was sitting in their office you
know just kind of [ __ ] around and
uh then bill hader came in i never met
him or whatever and he was like hey
what's up he's really nice
but i could i could like tell that he
saw that i was there and he was like
he's gonna get fired and he was just
i could tell that he was like oh this is
not a good idea buddy
really yeah well he wasn't he didn't say
that he felt it yeah
and he was right you don't need to go
hang out it was just they were my only
pals in new york that you know
that i really hung out with all the time
so so that was just kind of a [ __ ] up
and then it just made me really kind of
bitter towards new york
and i did get way better at stand up
because you know new york rules for
stand up but
but then i would come out to [ __ ] la
to do [ __ ] and then
getting on that plane to go back to new
york was so hard i was like what am i
doing i love it here this is where good
things happen
uh and then i finally convinced my um
ex-girlfriend
to move to la with me and then we came
back here
so uh yeah i just that year in new york
was real
it was really hard that's what i'm
saying i can't the high of getting your
a dream show and then being let go
and and the beast yeah and then being
surrounded by it yeah after it's got to
be
hell yeah yeah so that was very unfun
it's like um
i kind of just it's like if you're it
was it's a huge breakup but
you know it's like they broke up with me
i didn't break up with them only it's
like they break up with everybody
eventually but i hear you i know
it's like if your ex-girlfriend dumped
you and then
all of your friends hung out with and
tweeted about your ex-girlfriend
constantly and you're like she's a [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah uh yeah it's just like
you know
i i did like i did a big unfollow like
really kind of cleared everything and
now i'm like hey you know
like i watched it this year and i was
like hey that's fun you know i'm like
really happy for beck and kyle uh but
i don't need to is this the first year
you've watched yeah i watched the season
premiere this is the first
seven years yeah i watched it it didn't
like
[ __ ] me up like you know like it would
have a little bit ago
yeah yeah so that was wild it was just
like a wild
but like an exciting year you know what
i mean like thought i was gonna be a
movie star for like a year
well maybe three months before i got
blanked for 10 weeks
yeah but you know what you have to
believe that you have to believe that
what the [ __ ] are we doing it for if you
don't if you're just going in and going
i'm not going to make anything of this
then you're failing already you
have to believe you can do that you're
not delusional to believe it because
we've seen it happen so many times
i mean tons of of famous comedic actors
have come from
snl roots yeah and also like what i will
say that
really happened there was my confidence
got sucked out like the first
four episodes were so great because i
was like i'm the [ __ ] man like i
[ __ ]
am good at comedy this is great and then
you know you get told
no so much there that i was like what am
i
am i bad like it was really just a mind
[ __ ] to
you know to get a job thinking that
you're going
thinking you're great and then them
being like you're not great and it's
just like oh i
but you hired me what you know it was
like a real it was a real mind [ __ ] it
took a
took a bit to dig out of it let me ask
you this what was your audition that got
you what did you what did you do because
i've seen a lot of the others
stand up man cause i just wanted to do
yeah i mean i got it it was
out he it was my jff how were you 26 six
it was my jfl set that seth meyers had
seen or whatever he was there he's like
hey we should have this guy and i'd
submitted a tape earlier and i'm not
good at
impressions and they were like we
actually saw this guy before he's weird
because you tried impressions no i was
doing impressions that i could do
which was like hitler if he was into
troll dolls
yeah i was just like okay let's just get
out let's you know before we get into my
speech
i just gotta cleanse your hair got the
jewel full of belly but don't let the
jews seize the jewel
yeah so and they're used to like you
know [ __ ] whatever vin diesel they're
like this guy's doing hitler and troll
[ __ ]
yeah uh jake the snake robert like these
were my celebrity impressions and then
you got to do characters so like my
celebrity impressions were characters
you know i was like jake the snake
roberts was a celebrity impression of
mine where
he the government had taken his snakes
uh and he was just lamenting it uh
he's like the government the government
took the snakes
but he but he was uh there to um
it was there to it's just pretty funny
stuff he was it was at a children's
party he had been hired to be a
okay yeah yeah take the snake out he's
like sorry i don't have the snakes the
government is
breathing snakes telling the kids yeah
yeah yeah
uh what was the other celebrity one i
did i don't even [ __ ] remember
oh so that was gallagher okay then it
was a combo of gallagher
and gal gallagher's claim to thing was
he had gotten jake the snake back into
coke
uh it was terrible but they were like it
was weird and then they saw i could do
actual stand up and they're like okay
maybe this is a combo
and then and then uh so then
lauren came out and i did it at ios and
everyone was so nervous and so [ __ ]
out here you did it yeah
and then you know then in new york it's
a bunch of [ __ ] and then uh yeah how
many um
three three yeah and then uh first one
was here ios
well actually three i just count jfl as
one jfl they're like do what you did at
jfl out here at ios and ios they're like
after io west i'd gotten it i killed so
hard i killed have you ever been funnier
than you really are
yeah do you know what i mean yeah you're
like you're like not that funny
or you could say anything and they're
laughing like man yeah and it
only worked because uh i didn't take the
audition seriously at
all which i think that's what they dig
um and uh
yeah i walked out or whatever and like
everyone's so tight and their characters
are so tight and the mic
broke when i grabbed it and they were
they were like very adamant like if you
do
you do five minutes and we cut your mic
we [ __ ] cut it
and there's like 25 people on this
showcase and i was like oh okay whatever
and i walked out and i grabbed the my
the mic fell apart like it just like
i've never seen a mic fall
completely apart so i like
took like a minute and a half putting it
back together
and then uh the first thing i said was
uh that was a gross misuse of my time
yeah and it just like boom like oh
whatever this guy says we're in
uh and it worked yeah i tricked him and
then when i got there they're like oh we
were tricked
you got to get out here for a year yeah
yeah yeah
but um yeah just that that uh everything
had gone a little too
when i got it my i remember my best
friend from high school he's like
seems a little too easy and then he was
right it was just i i hadn't really
dealt with failure until until that and
now i'm a pro at it
look i let's take a quick break and tell
you about our sponsor upstart
now if you have multiple credit cards
you know that tracking multiple balances
due dates and website logins can be
stressful it can be confusing i'm going
through it right now i'm
having to make stronger passwords redo
everything and upstart makes things
simple with one monthly payment in one
place upstart is the fast and easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment i
know a lot of you out there have used it
that's why they're back you guys are
telling me how great it is
i'm using it i'm glad you are as well
upstart finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because they assess more than
just your credit score with a five
minute online rate check you can see
your rate
up front for loans from 1 000 to 50
000 you can get approved the same day
and you can receive your funds as fast
as one business day
if debt is taking over your life it is
time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew
don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com honeydew now let's get
back to the do
so you said also coming off the heels of
losing snl
you had another situation right so i
convinced this girl
to move with me to new york uh and she's
another reason why we stayed she's kind
of she was just like [ __ ] you i moved
i moved to new york and i was like okay
i'll stay with you or whatever and then
uh we go through this intense experience
together uh
you know she had some other issues or
whatever and it was just like really
intense i've got a therapy about i think
we called it trauma bonding
you know like we she had a really rough
year and i had a really
like we were i loved her very very very
much you know
um and then we got engaged like after
snl because you know i was like look we
went through [ __ ] hell
like this is great like let's get
married and then um
that went to [ __ ] like a month before
our
wedding uh pretty i mean
how long were you engaged just like four
months oh okay uh
oh wow so you you were gonna get married
in that quick
yeah you know we were both the same just
kind of like let's just do we weren't it
wasn't like a big wedding we're like
we'll just go get [ __ ] mario and
joshua tree we'll come back you know
like it was just
very um i don't know like whatever
hipster [ __ ] just we'll just go get
married no we don't we weren't gonna
have a party or any you know we were
gonna get married then have a party
that sort of [ __ ] and then i was like
the snl thing [ __ ] up my me thinking i
was funny
right so i went so deep into touring
to put out my first album to like as a
way to prove i was funny you know i
needed that
so i toured hard for about a year you
know like
gone every weekend uh and then doing
even
solo little music venue tours where i
would be gone for a month
and i [ __ ] up you know and i was i
didn't well
not cheating wise but i loved my
girlfriend so much but i was gone so
much
that she got pissed and then
i found out about some other [ __ ] and
then it was just like
i thought everything was great and in
one day it was just all gone forever
like it was just she's gone she she's
gone
uh and that's like you know my wife in
my head
uh what happened i don't i feel i you
don't have to get into the specifics
how did you end it i like who called off
the engagement
well no no i would i guess
i don't fault this girl for like bailing
because i was uh
i was a grouch you know i was just like
kind of not i was just
uh always kind of just you know like
i don't know i didn't know how to deal
with it i should have gone to therapy i
should have [ __ ] got it
well i had a friend um who did one year
and left and when he came i saw him i
was like go to therapy just go right now
go to there you gotta start going to
therapy because that really helps
it does i mean there's a lot of people
that don't know it's an option because
they
don't know anyone their family that's
ever gone their circle of friends don't
go
so and also there's still even i know
when i go
especially if the therapists have told
me that men just you know that machismo
[ __ ] that that still we're a small
percentage of the people that go to
therapy are male
and it's because we're you know we're
taught not to cry
hold it in push it down you know all
that [ __ ] but it uh
it definitely [ __ ] helps i had i had
a therapist fire me
did she say brooks walk me through your
day
but she was like what do you mean fired
you i was like i was like
i think i'm gonna like my ex had hit me
up
and i was like i think i'm gonna go on a
date with her and my therapist is like
brooks if you go on a date with this
woman that you have been talking about
for a year
i can't help you anymore and i was like
i'm gonna do it
and she's like i'm done you're done
you're like i've so then she like
transferred me to like an addiction
specialist she was like you're like
addicted to this thing
or whatever you know and then the
addiction one was like i was like i
don't like this this is
and then i stopped going so because i
was fixed fixed yeah we're all fixed
yeah exactly
i'm fixed too right yeah but it was like
uh i just
it was you know life was pretty good and
then
within a year like the two things i
like really cared about the most were
just
gone literally back to back like so
close yeah yeah and it's almost i have
i've had a best friend
die and that's way worse but
mentally uh easier to deal with
than having your best friend who was my
fiancee
just gone but like a few blocks away
you're like it was like she's dead but
she's not would you ever see her in the
neighborhood and cross paths
no no that's good nope which is
incredible yeah yeah
uh but it was i just was like it was
terrible and then [ __ ] the worst
thing of all time is goddamn
instagram you know what i mean with an
ex you
like like i would go like six months and
then i'd be like well let's cut
ourselves
and then you always hope they're posting
like
i'm sad yeah yeah all right they're
ruined without
you i live in a dirt pile
ah that's what you get wait yeah like
you're in it you're on an
island uh yeah so is this
um just dealing with that like and i
didn't i don't think i dealt with it
well
did you go to therapy after that no i
haven't been back
uh but it's fine i don't know but i was
it
like affected my stand-up i was a i was
a bummer on stage
and i used to be like well now i feel
like i'm back to like being happy and
excited and cool and fun
on stage but like for like that year
i've been there i i mean
excuse me a few breakups i was dark um
my just my my physical presence was
different like
you know just slow yeah very well said
you embody it you i would bum out a
party yeah just by being there
like ugh what a bummer
dude yeah no thanks so i had to like
kind of
just reckon with that and you know
really like it's so
dumb and how true it is but it's like oh
time heals i was just like no it won't
be sad forever
and now i'm like what you were that sad
dude it's going to be fine
yeah yeah yeah there are moments in the
within the moment that you think that
you there's no way you're getting out of
this that's not ever going to get better
it's not and then you
you know you pick yourself up and you
move forward and then you look bang
you're like what the [ __ ] was i thinking
yeah because you know why life throws
more [ __ ] at you and you're like oh man
this is some brand new [ __ ] that's way
worse than the other [ __ ] i thought was
the worst [ __ ] that's ever happened to
me
you realize you're not sad there's so
much worse things um like my best
best friend was this guy kevin barnett
who you heard of he's i know
yeah he's a new york guy yeah and i
never got to know him but everyone that
i know
that knew him in our world just loved
the dude yes
he was that one of those guys he's like
the best dude
ever uh like i went to hawaii with him
because i was all bumming and he was
like let's just [ __ ]
let's go to hawaii let's get over this
chick you know like that's the guy so me
and him was hawaii and had the best time
ever
uh and it was really fun and great and
then i was dating this new girl
this is only is not even two years ago
that this happened
and um things were things were good
things were awesome can i ask you a
quick question because there was a night
where it was you
me and emily laford who books the show
for me
um and works with us and also manages at
the comedy store
was because i had just lost an
engagement
you were seeing someone and just broke
up with somebody and she was just seeing
do you remember that night we're all in
that little landing in the belly room
and we were all talking like
are we all three like freshly dumped
right now for real
i mean was that the engagement i i don't
know it was just such a lo no because
that would have been new york
well no i was out here when the
engagement ended and i that's the only
person who's i've had relationships
since then and i
stopped those that would have been 2015.
yeah that's exactly what it was
it just hit me right now where i'm like
all three of us connected to this show
right now too or freshly [ __ ] dogs
yes
like and that was the worst energy to be
right people were like well just slide
by excuse me yes yes
oh i don't want to i don't want any of
this on me actually
yeah yeah that's right yes that's right
that was her um
that was that you know that was it
because i thought like oh
snl it doesn't get worse than snl i was
like oh this engagement it doesn't get
worse than this
and then kevin [ __ ] died i was like
this is kevin died
kevin died he had like sleep apnea and
he had [ __ ] um
pancreatitis oh man he died in his sleep
in [ __ ] mexico he's [ __ ] nuts he
was on vacation
yes i had been i had gone down to
tijuana with my new girlfriend the week
before
and i was like do tijuana rules it's
great like it's cheap
you [ __ ] tacos and uh mezcal flights
and it's so fun
and then kevin and his friends went the
next week and
he just didn't come back like i was like
you got to go to this tackle spot this
talk is about to stuck a spot
and um yeah and i have it still
comes up where i uh have meltdowns about
it because it's only a year
and a year like last january
two januarys ago who was he with brooks
he was with his high school friends
and so they wake up in the morning and
he's gone he's like he's
dead yes yeah in mexico
in mexico and then the craziest [ __ ] was
like we have to like get his
body back from excellent and then
there's like a person i wasn't doing it
his
our other friends joshua bennett and
jermaine fowler were like really helping
his dad
do get all this stuff and uh there's
like a [ __ ]
person whose job it is like oh yeah no
we do the bodies back to the united
states we're like oh jesus this is a
business
um so i didn't know how to deal with
that at
all uh how did you find out who who
i was in dude it was so bad like
it was just the worst i was in the joke
i had was
uh i was in a wendy's uh drive-through
and it was 7 30 in the morning i mean
wendy's drive there at 7 30 in the
morning
because i'd taken my new the girl i
dated for a while um
back to her uh house she had work that
day and so i'm just like in windy he's
like
got a new girlfriend things rock and
then um get a call
at 7 30 from nick turner who's our other
like best friend and um
i just answered what's up you know and
he's
screaming uh she's just scream he's
yelling and he just goes kevin barnett's
dead
and i was like no he's not the guy i
talked to him
yesterday like he's not dead and he's
like he's dead
and i was like what do you mean like
what do you mean he's like there's no
other way to tell you he's dead
uh and so then i just like i was like
i'm gonna come over to your house and
so we were calling peop so the worst
part was like hung up and you're just in
shock
he didn't even tell you how or anything
so you probably got a million things
running through your i knew kevin was
i knew he's in mexico yeah i don't know
what's going on right he didn't know if
he was murdered or yeah
so i'm like uh and he wouldn't even know
he was called by our other friend ed
larson it was just like
friend group calling real quick and then
the weird part was then i just still
waited in line and got my wendy's
you know because he's just like in a fog
and then went over to nix and we just
called
a bunch of people uh to tell them
uh you know just hey this happened hey
this happened this you know like a
little
let's let's tell people um before it's
[ __ ] everywhere and then the stand
in new york tweeted like we will miss
you kevin we're like you
[ __ ] psychopaths like
hit some of his family doesn't even know
yet you know like we're trying to tell
people like and then my friend turner
tweeted kevin hate at the stand
uh because he did yeah and then
it was just you know a real just uh
you you know what death is like it's
just like waves of
oh i've been not thinking about that for
a minute and i told you i had a meltdown
during election night this little past
like election or whatever when joe biden
won i was at
her other friend eric andres and only a
few people
few not a lot of people went to i mean a
lot of people went to kevin's funeral
but he was very he
he died in um uh he died in
i mean he died in mexico but he's from
palm beach so we'd go to florida
and talk about funny man like so i
stayed at this motel 6 in florida and i
was like broke at this time
uh well like two not broke but like i
can't be flying to palm beach you know
it was just like around like i was there
like
20 hours back and i say this motel 6 and
it's expensive
but it sucks because right on the beach
and i'm wearing a suit
and i go to my friend's funeral and
sobbing
and then come back and i'm in my suit at
like the motel 6 like walking in and
like they try to make fun of me they're
like
look at this [ __ ] he's wearing a suit
in a motel six i go my friend died
so but then you just had to get it out
yes i'm afraid i [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you yeah uh and then but then i uh
was at your country the other day i was
real drunk because joe biden went and i
was
like an amount of stress that had melted
off of me because i couldn't have dealt
with
i just couldn't have dealt with pandemic
and then also donald trump is still
president
i just couldn't it was the stress was so
deep so deep that whole week because i
was like i don't know
and then joe biden i don't even like joe
biden but i say donald trump
and i'm wasted at eric andrews just so
happy and so stoked and then our other
friend came
in who i hadn't seen since kevin's
funeral alana glazer and she's so nice
and great but i don't run into her that
often and it just like
just seeing her did it seeing her
drunk she has like a bird luger tattoo
which is
kevin uh and i just
melted down i s like sobbing like
everyone's like what the [ __ ] you know
and i
yeah that's when i was like i gotta go
to therapy like yeah so
just like hit me like i hadn't dealt
with it you know in like a while
and it was it was it was that was a
blubbering did you leave did you stay
oh i stay i stay
how much longer until like three in the
morning
it was a terrible decision this time
yeah eric's really nice he called me the
next day he's like you all right i was
like
yeah i think uh sorry he's like it's
okay
but you scared some people yes you did
yes he's like you uh you were pretty
wild i was like yeah no i uh
uh i'm gonna go there um but yeah so
that and then i cried about kevin a few
days ago
it's just because like this is the time
like the time where you're like
this is when i would be hanging out with
kevin you know this lockdown i'm like
this is where i would be with kevin
playing video games you know like this
is where
yeah he would be showing me some new
music video and it would just be us
talking about how
[ __ ] everything was like that's was
that he was at
you know so it's like oh the guy uh
that i would be spending the most time
with right now
is gone during the weirdest time ever i
i was talking about how kevin did it
right
he bounced at the right time how old was
he he was thirty two he was thirty two
damn we were like
a few days apart in age so was there
ever an autopsy done it was definitely
from the patriot
yeah man we were i mean like did he know
he had that
i don't know he had sleep apnea we
shared so many hotel rooms
and he would just like yeah so it was
like he needed like a sleep app machine
or so i
i don't know i just know his
pancreatitis and i was really
like stoked that it was pancreatic you
know what doesn't mean it's just like
yeah
it doesn't matter he's dead but i
remember like
somebody was like well was it drugs i'm
like who gives a [ __ ]
like [ __ ] you for even saying that [ __ ]
like who cares he's gone
and it wasn't it's incredible which you
know
like not that he did him but i'm like i
would have been bummed if it was you
know because i was like oh damn it you
know but
i know what you mean because i had a
friend who died in a car crash and i
just i was like please don't
let alcohol come back yeah toxicology
and it didn't and i was like
you know i don't know why he's she's
gone yeah and
i don't know why but it does make me
feel better that it
it was tragic and not some foolish
[ __ ] mistake that's
and look man yeah it's like i just want
whenever i die
people to be like well that's why you
don't do that
you know what i mean yeah yeah well
that's why you don't do that
let brooks be a lesson yeah look at this
and this is why we don't okay like
that's my whole goal
just not to be a [ __ ] not to be an
example of a
[ __ ] dumb death yeah exactly that's
why like people like it sucked to go
down in a plane crash i'm like that's
the way to go
not my fault baby you know what you just
changed my thought on that because i
paranoid about that all i worry about is
like is this guy in good health up there
this lady up there
[ __ ] paying attention what the [ __ ]
are they doing up there
yeah but you're right it's not my fault
yeah i just don't want to be myself
i'm not responsible that's tragic yeah
exactly oh man so much life to live
yeah damn it it's a rare thing
[Laughter]
so how has that changed your view on
life did it what did it do to you
um other than make you sad obviously
does it does it make you appreciate
comedy more
friends more did it make you it made me
it made me way
closer with kevin's group of friends
okay
you know what i mean like everybody was
at that funeral because kevin was a new
york dude
and just had lived in la a few years and
like i was
mostly friends with those guys through
kevin because we met
when we were 25 hosting comedy central
had a hot tub time machine
thing or whatever and then me and kevin
hosted it was the first thing we ever
did on tv we hosted the interstitials
for
you're watching hot tub time machine you
know and then we became best
friends because we were sitting in this
hot tub all day uh and
it was just like you know a perfect way
to meet a pal and then you know we go to
montreal together
and then everything starts happening
together he makes this show friends of
the people when i get snl
and like we're just having fun success
yeah
and it was great um and but i really
just mostly hung with kev
and then through all this i became way
better friends closer friends with
everybody else who has the exact same
amount of great things
and great stories about kevin because i
didn't meet him twitter 25 he'd been
you know in new york hustling for five
years before that
um but i don't i would just say of
anything
i don't even know i mean i think i
really haven't dealt with it i've just
been like yeah
and uh i don't know it just sucks i
don't see any positivity in it
there's no positivity in it i can't i
can see you know what i mean
so there's no like i learned lessons
from you know being fair enough snl and
an engagement ending of like
oh you know you can grow on these this
one i don't see any growth
that's where therapy comes in yeah yeah
because i'm just like there's no
positive about that
that's there's no well that happened
because it's nothing
all bad so yeah it just sucks but you
haven't seen
the positive sense of anything
from kevin dying no i can't hasn't made
you change your life in a positive way
not i don't i don't mean specifically he
died this
i mean what has the collateral damage
have you turned any of that into
positivity yet
is there anything that that that made
you go you know what
[ __ ] it i'm gonna do this or i'm gonna
think that or whatever
i always connect with anyone yeah i
don't know man
it was just i don't think so i was
already doing all that stuff like kevin
was the guy who would go with me on the
trips i go on by myself now
like yeah they're camping yeah yeah so i
go solo
like kevin was the dude who would be
down because you know we were all like
i'd love to do that i'd love to do that
i love do that we all say it
nobody does it he was my friend who
would come with
you know or we would go do this like
so maybe if anything he's it's let me be
a lot
more okay by myself i guess because you
know
i wasn't camping alone before kevin
passed and now i do it all the time and
it's like
slightly more at peace with myself i
guess i don't know
because i just can't imagine anything
worse happening so i'm just like well
whatever i'm gonna go
might as well go uh uh look at some
stuff
i don't know it's a bummer i don't i
can't think of a pod i'm just like
spinning trying to be like no
this is but not here you know if you you
haven't you haven't it's still
only you said a year and a half yeah
it's not a long time
at all at all especially when we're
talking about forever
like that's the thing i always think
about like that person's gone
forever you know doesn't matter how long
you [ __ ] live
nothing ever again and it's like brutal
i remember thinking that about my dad
when when i was 16 like
wait i don't even ever get to say hi
again or a wave
down to nothing it's it's yeah
it couldn't be more permanent no it's
wild uh
i mean yeah i i yeah and i guess
meeting i'd met kevin's brothers and
they're cool and they came out to ellie
and we hung out and that was nice but
like
i already knew him before that yeah yeah
uh
but i mean it's just like it's kind of
like uh any time where
i'm with hit our old group of friends we
just tell kevin stories all the time
which is
i guess you know man i was i was telling
i was telling my friend a kevin joke
yesterday like i was like man this guy
had this best joke and it was so funny
kevin's
big black dude but uh was
had this also just weird subversive
comedy style and he was so nice and
sensitive even
he's like one day i want to um he's like
one day i want to wake up early this is
in new york he's like put on a suit
and get a briefcase and go to uh and go
to
wall street and go into a busy building
and have my briefcase
uh pop open and just have a bunch of
uh photos of dragons that i've drawn
fallout
and i'll go oh no my documents and it
was just like he would tell in a way
better way but just like that was a
kevin joke
yeah you want to take dragon drawings to
wall street and call them your documents
and dude the funniest thing the hardest
i ever laughed too was probably
uh kevin we were doing montreal another
year kevin hart's
lol or whatever and you had to sign this
paper that was like you can't do these
jokes again on television and i was like
whatever i'm going to no one's going to
chase this you know what i mean
and kevin was pissed uh he was like no
i'm just gonna bomb i'm just gonna bomb
and it's taped he's like i'm just gonna
bomb
and so he goes up and he starts bombing
on purpose he's like blah blah blah
like not doing anything and people start
like booing him
this isn't my drill nobody gets booed at
what no they're like oh
you know and then he was like he he goes
okay he tried to stop he's like all
right stop
stop stop okay i was i was bombing on
purpose
now i'm gonna try now i'm gonna do my
real jokes because he didn't like it
he didn't like being booed and then so
he goes into his real jokes
and they're like no and he's still bored
yeah and he goes and then he goes now
y'all just being disrespectful
that was like the funniest thing i've
ever seen is gonna watch i'm gonna get
you back actually no
i don't like this this hurts he goes
this is hurting my feelings yeah
it was so funny yeah he's like that dude
he's like i guess it's
nice you get to tell the stories and
then you feel good about it that's it i
mean that's all you have that's all we
have what else can you [ __ ] do
there's nothing you can look at maybe
photos
which hurts a lot too um
you know it's funny someone sent me
recently a video of my grandmother who i
just
she could still be here i missed the
[ __ ] out of that lady she was like
a mom to me did so much for us and i
heard her voice
and in my head it sounded a little
higher pitched than i remembered and i
thought god damn it's been that long
since i've heard your voice that i
i didn't even know and i started
thinking about like my father's voice
and anybody i'm like
i don't know if i really remember i i
can hear what i think they sound like
but
obviously my memory was not reality and
i was like
man she sounds different there whoa and
i was blown away by
that's fine by that [ __ ] um have you
gone back and watched any of his clips
or any of that stuff yeah i mean he was
also
the other annoying part about kevin was
not annoying he was really busy but he
never he wasn't
he never did a late night set because he
never tried to he was like busy making
the sketch show friends of the people
and busy making rel's show
and being really successful but he never
did like a late night set but uh i
watched like sketches he did and he's so
funny in it um he made a comment central
pilot called kevin versus josh that
with joshua binowitz that josh sent me
and i watched that only recently
and that was he's fully acting and it's
really funny and he's being kevin and it
was really
yeah it was just uh it just spins me out
for a little bit
it's not fun yeah yeah i know it
uh i'm trying to think about oh one okay
and here's one other kevin story that
was really good that this is
this is the last night i saw kevin uh we
were at some party
like in hollywood or whatever and i uh
i liked mushrooms and i just took
mushrooms uh
by myself i was just tripping on
mushrooms and i just enjoying it and uh
a standing in the lawn like and when i'm
on mushrooms and other
everybody else is just like drinking and
partying and stuff or at this moment i
was just like look at these [ __ ]
[ __ ] like they need to
party and whatever you know like bunch
of weirdos you know
uh and then kevin came over to me and
he's like what's up and i was like
everyone here is being nuts he goes
no only you
you guys you're standing on the lawn
alone buddy
he's like let's get you around a group
of people cause
over there they're talking about you
yeah so you just you know look out for
me like hey man come on you gotta go
[Laughter]
yeah i know that is somebody you missed
that's a real friend right yeah yeah
like not out of that no no you're being
weird
you're to be fair you're standing alone
in the lawn staring at
strangers oh man yeah uh uh so yeah
just that stuff but i guess really uh
all i learned was
um what i really learned i guess is to
enjoy
things when they're good you know what i
mean yeah i didn't know that i didn't
enjoy a second of snl i should have
it it was cool it was really neat and i
was too busy worrying about
getting back versus enjoying it in the
moment
so like now i kind of try to let myself
enjoy things in the moment a little bit
you know like i used to be like
oh hey you you booked to do like uh
the half hour or whatever like all right
well how do i get the hour
you know like now i would have been like
cool let's have fun at this half hour
yeah that's a great that's great advice
actually it really is because
you know you look back on all these cool
things because it doesn't
feel they i hear this a lot from like
professional athletes when they win a
super bowl or whatever they're like
you don't you're you're living it so
it's not like it's when you look
back on it where you're like oh man that
was [ __ ] awesome
like that was awesome it is very hard to
be
present what you're talking about
instead of but but the hustle mentality
is that like because as soon as that
half hour is done and recorded and it
airs
the next morning you wake up and that is
okay what's next
yeah and if you're not being proactive
on what's next
then you're starting from zero right
there when you could have a head jump
but you're right you have to be
uh mentally present really try to enjoy
that yeah
just like allowing allowing a pat on the
back from yourself every once in a while
that's right and not because i'm very
like it could have been better it could
have been better i could be doing this i
could be doing this i could be
instead of being like look man you tried
real hard and you did already you came
from here you went all the way to snl
you were only supposed to write but you
gotta
you know it's it's so much harder to do
that for yourself yeah other people can
do that for you and you can listen and
be like yeah
but it's it is uh hard to look in that
mirror and
and go positive instead of negative it's
so easy to go yeah oh man
nick crowell has one of my f that guy's
so [ __ ] funny he is one of my
favorite jokes i heard
and maybe maybe i shouldn't well it's
fine basically he was just talking about
can you imagine looking in the mirror
and being like
yep i like it like he tells it much
better but it was just like
god it was so funny it's just such a
good joke he's like god that'd be nuts
just to look at yourself and
like it like i was like oh this is so
good he's great
all right so this is your first time on
the show so i'm going to ask you a
question i ask everybody
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self because yours is kind of
interesting most people
have sort of had some trauma around then
and it shapes and affects
their way moving forward but yours
didn't really hit until later you were
saying
you're curious what you would say to
yourself i mean i just i had two really
mean older brothers so it wasn't like i
had it wasn't like
[ __ ] was great they're cool now but they
were not cool
uh but they're great now i love them now
um and i have a joke about it how it
would be weird to go
ah about uh when i was eight i promised
i would kill them
as an adult but it'd be weird to do it
now
yeah it would be really weird hey merry
christmas i gotta kill you
when i was eight i decided my hands
weren't big enough at the time but now
they're pretty big
um i don't know man i would
just say uh don't uh i don't know how
you can
i just when i'm in relationships i get
too attached i guess uh uh
so i would say hey hey psycho maybe i'd
maybe take a week off before you date
new new people every once in a while
i'll tell you that
maybe maybe you do a year with where you
learn how to um
go to bed alone not you know just like
like right now i'm living in my
apartment alone and it's like
nice but it took me to get to 34 to be
able to do that a pandemic
yeah well i just had i went from
girlfriend to roommates to girlfriend
to you know then the girlfriend
roommates and now i'm like yo let's
[ __ ] chill for a sec maybe this is
you know figure this out so maybe that's
advice i'm just giving me
as a 34 year old
it applies yeah hey psycho maybe read a
book tonight
dude thank you for coming on and sharing
all this stuff yeah it was
good i hope i didn't over talk no you're
you're the guest you're supposed to talk
right i know i have a podcast where
sometimes the guest doesn't talk i'm
like what are you doing
yeah come on it's your turn yeah yeah
yeah um will you please promote
everything again
just my podcast entry level uh it's good
um and yeah ryan's on it and uh any
comics you
there's comic you would like on it i
guarantee for sure yeah like bill burr
did it not that long ago
uh people seem to think he's funny yeah
a little bit
i remember he did it and then like
hosted snl the next week i was like all
right
that's pretty this is a pretty good gift
yeah i'd say so yeah uh
yeah just listen to that check out my
stand um
watch friends of the people kevin's show
yeah that was that's no longer it was a
true tv thing
uh if you want to see how funny that
dude was um yeah just that [ __ ]
all right well thank you for coming on
man and uh oh wait time out
here we go one this is another great
this ties it all together a little bit
this is how good of a friend kevin is
kevin um one time he was he was over at
our place in new york a lot
and he uh saw my ex fiance
or whatever and she was like hey kevin
and he just goes nah
as a buddy that's a real friend right
respectful but now
oh that shit's great man yeah
good dude man well thank you you're a
good dude too thank you thank you this
was really funny this was fun thank you
sitting down that's all right that's
that's tough stuff to talk about man
yeah but some it's also like so uh you
know so
like i'm always like everybody's had it
way worse because the people have
but it's cathartic you really say it is
it totally is who should work
thank you man and uh thank you all as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
you